The Moonstone was a large yellow diamond that was famous in the history of India.
Three priests were given the job of watching the diamond day and night.
When the priests grew old, they were replaced by other priests.
Hundreds of years passed.
Then, a Mogul emperor attacked the city and took the diamond.
The three priests could not take it back by force,...
...but they followed the diamond as it passed from one emperor to another.
At last, the Sultan of Seringapatam put the diamond in the handle of a dagger...
...and put it in his treasury.
Then, in 1799, the British Army attacked Seringapatam.
The soldiers heard stories about the yellow diamond,...
...but the general of the army said, the soldiers were not to take any treasure.
However, a greedy officer called Herncastle,...
...killed the three Indian priests and took the diamond.
The last of the priests to die told him that the diamond would bring him bad luck.